accused sexual predator Nathan chasing
horse trying to get his charges tossed
good evening to you I'm Brian Loftus I'm
David charns in for Denise tonight the
attorney for the Dances with Wolves
actor making an argument which a
prosecutor says offends her a new cell
investigator Vanessa Murphy following
this case closely she has the latest on
the fireworks in court we do want to
warn you this story is of a sensitive
nature
see two alleged victims are at the
center of the case against Nathan
chasing horse in Clark County in an
effort to get the charges against him
tossed out public defender Christy
Holston makes this argument about one of
the women sex for a transactional
purpose
is not successful she chose to have sex
in exchange for something prosecutor
Stacy Collins saying she's offended by
that claim and that the woman had been
groomed as a child she's taken there at
14 because her mom is ill
and
told that her virginity is the only pure
part of her left and she has to
sacrifice this
to maintain her mom's health chasing
horses accused of victimizing indigenous
underage girls and women for two decades
as he traveled throughout the United
States and Canada he was arrested in
North Las Vegas in January and now faces
federal charges and at least two
warrants in Montana and Canada as more
alleged victims come forward with
similar stories like this now you have
these these kids that have been raised
in this religious environment to worship
Him and respect him and follow him and
listen to him and now ultimately they
become emotionally attached chasing
horse remains in jail in downtown Las
Vegas his trial is set for May 1st
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now